now the last of you here you were
talking about how you're trying to
combine the five belts yes the 11 but
you have added one you've now got
freakin awesome entry now you've got
four yes okay
little by little step by step so what
was the last one you got this ad what
when I was about to book shows at Parker
well this is the New Zealand guy yes
I played a part of this we showed a
picture of him and I just casually said
he looks like he's eaten some pie and
you forget that the show is shown in
other places 100 G's New Zealand yeah
obviously he's not training much he's
sitting so he saw the show and so I but
bless him he did bother to tweet trust
me all right
and then the hashtag Gray map I thought
he'd misspelled my name but in fact
that's a New Zealand bakery I think it's
like you did in Gray's was it is easier
fight as I predict [ __ ] yeah it was
thank you it wasn't like a slugfest like
garden yeah it was just more of a
technical boxing much secured a belt and
then I can go on to get in the 54th now
you've announced that you're going to be
fighting at the 13th of April on Wembley
that's all booked in it's lovely are you
training for that now you're training
for the air training but imagine no
opponent you know that does seem a
technical diary
you can see why if you have problems
getting opponents because you know
obviously a gold medalist when the
Olympic four of the five chubby belts 22
professional fights has never lost and
has finished all but one of those fights
today by knockout so now is it still
decay so you need this fifth belt
correct so this is the guy that has the
fifth belt yeah Deontay Wilder now I
look at him and I think how bad is for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's a nice even number I mean really
one nickname could we call him I'm not
making it all New Zealand pie man
is he refusing to fight you know he just
got four options he's got other options
in the states that he's interested in
fighting but my view is that before
you've got the last one it's like Lord
of the Rings let's combine them together
yeah you can fight in front of the
biggest audience the best UK crowd there
is and fight for the heavyweight
championship of the world that's a great
offer but he's interested in fighting
someone else so I have to go a different
route at the minute cuz he gets the
other four if he beats you he gets the
other four yeah I can't actually like
say I'm gonna defend one today and leave
the rest at home then differend another
yeah yeah yeah it may be scared yes
let's look at him again new
[Laughter]
[Music]
you